I already have trouble regulating my
emotions.
I have a suspicion it's to do with the
fact that I'm 90 percentile and
openness,
conscientiousness and neuroticism and
second percentile in agreeableness and
extroversion.
Any tips on dealing with that?
Yeah,
well,
if you're really high in openness and
you're really high in neuroticism,
that can be a rough combination.
The conscientiousness should actually
help without,
although it might make you a bit
perfectionistic.
The problem with being high in openness
which is creativity and interest in
ideas and high in neuroticism,
which is tendency towards anxiety and
emotional pain,
is that like open people like to break
open boxes,
conceptual boxes and see what's inside
like Pandora's box,
but people are high in neuroticism or
are more likely to respond negatively to
complexity and uncertainty and if you're
an open person and you're always
thinking up new things you you tend to
saw off the branch that you're sitting
on on a regular basis and that can be
pretty destabilizing.
Any tips on dealing with that?
Well,
I would repeat what I said earlier.
I think that one of the things that you
do if you're high in anxiety is to
stabilize your sleep wake cycles,
so get up at the same time,
go to bed at the same time and eat at
the same time.
Make sure that you eat breakfast and a
big breakfast too.
That's heavy on fat and protein because
if you're hungry and then you stress
yourself,
especially if you're high in
neuroticism,
you destabilize your,
your insulin production system and it
will restabilize till you go to sleep
again.
So I would say like two things.
One is have a big breakfast and then
also if you're feeling particularly
anxious,
try eating something,
not carbohydrates and see if that helps
because you.
You might be somewhat permanently
dysregulated in your insulin,
stress-related insulin production.
That would be worth trying.
I would also say that you should shield
yourself to some degree from news
sources and sources of bad news,
especially catastrophic news because
most of it isn't news.
It's the repetition of things that we
already know full well,
and there's reason to protect yourself
from an onslaught of negative
information,
especially when it's not really
necessary for you.
I mean,
I don't think you should bury your head
in the sand,
but constant exposure to the
catastrophes of the world,
especially when there's nothing that you
can do about those catastrophes even
hypothetically,
is something that can really destabilize
people.
I often tell people in my clinical
practice,
um,
which isn't operating right now by the
way,
um,
to shield themselves from news reports
because it's just too much.
If you're depressed and anxious,
it's just not something that you need.
It's not helpful to you.
Second percentile in agreeableness and
extroversion.
Well know one of the things that you can
do if you're that low in agreeableness
that shouldn't disregulate your
emotions,
but it might interfere with your
relationships with other people you
know,
because you might be a little bit harder
to.
You might take other people's feelings
into consideration less than might be
good for you.
One of the things that people who are
low in agreeableness can do is to try to
think of things they could do for other
people and make that a practice.
You know,
like maybe once a week you could
consciously do someone a favor or give
someone a gift,
something like that.
And practice being,
um,
what would you call it,
compassionate and polite,
you know,
that'll expand your personality rather
than transforming it.
So then maybe you could have the
advantages of being disagreeable,
which means you're tough minded and
skeptical and competitive and,
and those can all be really good things,
but it would be nice to be able to leave
it out a little bit with some,
with the ability to take other people's
perspectives a bit more and to take them
into account.
And then,
you know,
if your relationships improve,
that can also improve your emotional
stability because one of the ways that
people regulate their anxieties by
having people around them that they get
along with.
Because you know,
if you're,
if the upset people,
then they upset you.
And especially if you're high in
neuroticism and that can increase your
anxiety.
And your pain.
So.